Let's look at the answer to
our fault classification quiz.
The phone got wet.
By cause,
it's definitely an environmental fault.
What kind of fault by duration is it?
Getting wet is a transient fault.
Eventually it gets dry.
The explosion would have been
a permanent fault from which you
really cannot recover, but
getting wet is only a transient fault.
Now because the phone was supposed to
prevent itself from running when wet,
the fact that it did heat up, and
it wasn't suppose to,
is an indication of a design fault.
So really,
it was suppose to not do this but
the way it was designed actually made
it do that, so it's a design fault.
And design faults
are typically permanent.
And this is one more example
of when you can have a fault
that never becomes an error or failure.
So the permanent fault of
being poorly designed so
that when it gets wet it can heat up and
explode would never become an error or
a failure until we actually
get that particular phone wet.